[موسيقى]
من اهم نشاطات الجمعيه عندنا هي رعايه
الجوارح وخصوصا الطيور اللي بتقع او تتمسك
في وقت الهجره والتوعيه بالطيور والانواع
اللي تنفع لنشاطره في مصر والمخاطر اللي
بتتعرض لها والانواع اللي ما تنفعش اصلا
للسقاره واللي بتتمسك مع الصيادين او
بتوقع مصابه في اي مكان
الثور طبعا مهمه جدا في البيئه انا عن
نفسي شايف ان تواجد الجوارح في ال- اا في
البيئه هو نوع من انواع الحفاظ على حياه
الانسان لان احنا بنتكلم في ان ربنا خلق
لنا درع طبيعي بيننا وبين الافات وبين كل
الحاجات اللي ممكن تاثر على صحه الانسان
وعلى مصادر غذاءه المشكله همم اللي بيساء
استخدام
الصقور وفي الصيد الجائر للصقور بخلاف ان
مصر موقعها على اتفاقيه سايدس اللي هي
تنظيم تجاره بالحيوانات البريه
[موسيقى]